here's what would actually happen if
tick tock got banned
is it terrifying hashtag save tick tock
tick tockers have been taken to tick
tock to express their fears over a
potential u.s ban
similar to india where the app was
blocked in late june for cyber security
concerns
they are worried they'll no longer have
access to the fun music and video driven
app
the trump administration has indicated
that it's considering similar action
or at least limiting americans access to
the popular app
with respect to chinese apps on people's
cell phones i can assure you the united
states will get this one right too
so here's why the us is concerned about
tick tock on american phones
tick tock is china's first global social
media sensation
in just a few years it has quickly
vaulted into the top app download ranks
neck and neck with other popular apps
but with this kind of popularity has
come
increased scrutiny from washington to
collect everything from the device
you're using to access the app your ip
address
the messages exchanged with other users
on the tick tock
itself and to be very honest that is not
very different from what
facebook youtube twitter and other
social media apps are collecting
the difference with tick tock is its
ownership its parent company is bite
dance which is based in beijing
tik tok doesn't have a headquarters
although its ceo sits in los angeles
china's legal system allows it to
request user data from companies
what worries foreign governments is the
fact that the firewall between user data
and the chinese government is completely
removed
because of these laws and that means
american private data
might end up in the hands of the chinese
government what beijing could do next
with this trove of american data is also
a concern
u.s officials are concerned that the
chinese government could be
building a vast database of information
based off
whatever they've gotten from tiktok
users and that pool of information
might be potentially used for more
nefarious means
such as espionage tiktok has said that
the chinese government has never asked
the company for user data
and would refuse such a request the
company also said its data on american
users is held in servers outside of
china
in the u.s and singapore there are also
concerns about freedom of expression
among the fun quirky videos uploaded to
tiktok every day
some users say that some videos have
been censored
the journal found that in the last two
years employees at tiktok followed rules
that included striking out content
that was in line with censorship norms
in china for example
showing tattoos or excessive cleavage
and politically sensitive topics
including the hong kong protests or
tiananmen square
recently the app has been censoring
other types of content too
we found one u.s user who said she was
banned from her account because
she had kissed her girlfriend on the
cheek and this happened during a live
stream
on tick tock and tick tock basically
told her after
that her account was banned for serious
pornography tick tock said that
moderation decisions are in an effort to
keep the tone on the app
light-hearted and not in the name of
censorship
tick-tock isn't facing only scrutiny
from the u.s tick-tock
is facing a possible ban in australia
the dutch data protection agency
is launching an investigation into
tick-tock where pressure grows tick-tock
is taking measures to distance itself
from its chinese roots
there's now an american ceo at the head
of tick-tock
his name is kevin mayer and he comes
from disney and by dance is also
considering other changes
to its corporate structure people
familiar with the discussions
tell us that bike dance is thinking of
establishing a headquarters for
tick-tock
outside of china as the u.s and china
clash over coronavirus
citizens rights in hong kong and
xinjiang the south china sea
and trade tech has become a major
sticking point
and after huawei and zte tick tock has
become the latest giant to be threatened
by the us government
and the ones who will watch particularly
closely how tick-tock handles
the politics of the global marketplace
will be its fellow chinese tech
companies
what's really interesting here is that
bike dance is arguably the most
successful chinese internet export
and should the app be banned it doesn't
bode well for other chinese companies
who are seeking to go global